s'agissant du calendrier dans lequel le
nous allons mettre en oeuvre les
propositions et les mesures qui ont été
annoncées par le président de la
république comme nous en avons discuté
monsieur le président l'objectif du
gouvernement est de proposer au conseil
des ministres un projet de loi qui
viendra reprendre l'ensemble des mesures
annoncées par le président de la
république au conseil des ministres donc
de mercredi prochain
et l'idée est que ce projet puisse être
soumis à l'assemblée nationale puis au
sénat dans les meilleurs délais et être
adopté si les assemblées le souhaitent
avant la fin de la session ordinaire
je vous remercie
pouvez vous nous préciser les modalités
concrètes d'application de toutes ces
annonces concernant la csg
il s'agit d'exonérer de la hausse de
l'année 2018 les retraités qui prises
individuellement ont un revenu une
retraite inférieure à 2000 euros net par
mois
cela concerne trois millions sept cent
mille retraités et donc la moitié des
retraités qui ont vu leur csg augmenté
en 2018 verront cette année cette
augmentation annulés au cours de l'année
2019 cela concerne pour être un peu plus
précis les retraités dont le revenu
fiscal de référence et la notion est
importante est inférieur à 22 1581 80
euros par mois pour une personne seule
et lorsque ces personnes vivent en
couple ou enfouis dans des foyers
fiscaux de deux personnes ou plus
nous maintenons les règles de calcul au
niveau du foyer soit pour un couple
trente quatre mille six cents euros
je pense encore au projet de reprise à
ce que valent dans le nord est moins
fort pour ford sur lesquels je sais que
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances est particulièrement mobilisée
nous aimerions connaître vos
propositions pour ces français qui
ressentent tout autant le ras-le-bol
fiscales et sociales
je viens d'apprendre par un simple
communiqué de presse que ford refusait
l'offre de reprise de punch sur l' usine
de blanquefort à bordeaux je suis
révolté je suis écoeuré par cette ces
décisions qui ne se justifie que par la
volonté de ford de faire monter son
cours de bourse
je veux dénoncer la lâcheté de ford à
qui je demande de parler depuis trois
jours et qui n'a même pas eu le courage
de prendre le miz économie et des
finances au téléphone je veux dénoncer
le mensonge de ford qui dit dans ce
communiqué que l'offre de reprise de
punch n'est pas crédible alors que nous
y travaillons depuis des mois avec les
salariés avec punch et qu'elle souhaite
une offre industrielle crédible solide
qui garantit l'avenir du site industriel
de blanquefort et je veux dénoncer la
trahison de ford vis-à-vis des plus de
800 salariés du site du blanquefort à
qui je veux rendre hommage parce qu'ils
avaient accepté de réduire leur salaire
de réduire leurs rtt de faire des
efforts considérables pour garantir la
reprise
ils ont été trahi par ford les salariés
les syndicats
monsieur philippe poutou ont été à la
hauteur de leurs responsabilités
là où ford ne l'a pas été et je veux
profiter la représentation nationale
pour appeler ford solonnellement à
réviser sa décision et accepter la
reprise de punch qui garantit l'avenir
du site industriel de blanquefort à
bordeaux
[Musique]